andrew morton is the journalist that the
princess of wales
hand-picked to reveal her disillusion
with royal
life she even gave him a nickname noah
short for
noted author and historian his 1992 book
diana her true story revealed her deep
unhappiness with her marriage
few people knew her mind better and he
says that when bbc reporter martin
bashir walked into her world
he changed it forever but not
for better good morning
andrew you were the person who in a way
started this
entire chain of events with your book
what did you make of martin bashir's
interview in the sunday science this
morning
in which he said i never wanted to harm
diana in any way
and i don't believe we did
well when i first watched the interview
back in 1995
it was like watching the tv version of
diana her true story
so bashir used duplicitous means to get
diana to sit down
in in her sitting room and give the
interview but she was the one who owned
what she had to say
so an awful lot of what she did say had
been circulating before that
but because it came out of her mouth it
seemed sensational
raw and new do you think
that she would have done this interview
anyway with
somebody somewhere if
she hadn't done it with martin bashir
yeah
oh absolutely there's a queue a mile
long outside kensington palace oprah
winfrey barbara walters
clive james david frost the bbc had
their own man nicholas witchell who
had two meetings with her and then
bashir swooped in and said
i've got uh contacts with earl spencer
we're
looking down a different road and his
boss said
stan stand back so there's no question
at
all that diana was going to speak her
mind i think there may be an allegedly
in there somewhere andrew but
but i think that the central point i i
really wanted to get at is
would he have got this interview if he
had not lied or would it have gone
somewhere else
uh he wouldn't have got it it's as
simple as that he scared her half to
death
he he had her thinking that he had
contacts inside mi5 he was very
plausible
he arranged meetings in underground car
parks
scary places at the best of times but
when you think that your life is in
danger it was
it was very potent so she was
she was put in a state of fear and
trepidation um
and that encouraged her to speak out and
she
and so when she gave the interview it
wasn't a question of self-indulgence as
many people thought
but it was a question of self
preservation she thought that she was a
target
she thought that what from what bashir
said she was
she was um under the gun
or in the in the sights of the
establishment and remember
she lived like this for most of her
adult life
so in a way you're lining up with the
the duke of cambridge here because
prince william
said last week it is my view that the
deceitful way the interview was obtained
substantially influenced what my mother
said the interview was a major
contribution to making my parents
relationship
worse and has since hurt countless
others
and his brother said the ripple effect
of a culture of exploitation
and unethical practices ultimately took
her life i mean in a sense
what all three of you appear to be
saying is
that the manner in which martin bashir
got this provoked a kind of
i think the words has been used as
paranoia in the princess
that meant that what she then said uh
was
reflected that fear
now i i i disagree with william and
harry on this
and and i do find it ironic that it's a
bunch of
old etonians uh including earl spencer
who think there's a line between
the interview and diana's death i mean
diana wanted to speak her truth
and and she'd been stifled for a long
time
so yes she was she was terrified into
doing the interview by bashir
but no well what she had to say was
very much reflected what you really
truly felt three of us in the marriage
queen of people's hearts all these
things that she would have probably said
these kinds of things to somebody else
uh nicholas whitchloss
some other uh journalist it so happened
that bashir
uh beat the pack by lying to her and
that's how he did it
where do you think this leaves relations
between the royal family and the bbc
well relations between the bbc and the
royal family were
at an all-time low after the panorama
interview they
they uh really turned their backs on
them and they've been rebuilt over the
years
now of course when you've got these
extraordinary public statements given by
uh prince william and prince harry uh
attacking the bbc then they've got a
long way to go to restore that trust
you're a distinguished journalist andrew
um
how does what's been revealed by
this scandal leave you feeling
about our trade
well this is
this is the phone tapping moment for the
bbc and remember
the news of the world was involved in
tapping
uh harry and william's phones and that
that newspaper was shut down
this this is a a black day for for
british journalism
and and i think that we should all
reflect on
how you obtain an interview and the
process by which
you carry it forwards the bbc's
phone tapping moment thank you very much
andrew morton